This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever noticed, when you offer a friend or a colleague or a partner a suggestion for improvement, they often experience an urge to defend themselves? Rather than listen to how they might change or do something better, they try to preserve the status quo. Like generals fighting a war, they try to protect every square inch of the person they are, instead of embracing the person they might become. In our episode last week, winning the battle against yourself, we looked at how we often fail to make changes in our lives
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。你有没有注意到，当你向朋友、同事或伴侣提出改进建议时，他们往往会产生一种为自己辩护的冲动？
because our best intentions are at odds with what scientists call the value system in the brain. This brain network tends to prioritize the here and now and nudges us toward immediate gratifications instead of long-term benefits. If you missed that episode, I'd urge you to go back and listen to it in this podcast feed. Today, we look at one of the most powerful reasons we fail to make changes in our lives. Very often, the people around us can see what we need to do differently or better. But when they tell us, when they offer us feedback or, heaven forbid, criticism, we respond with anger, with denial, with defensiveness.
因为我们的最佳意愿与科学家所说的脑内价值系统相悖。这种大脑网络倾向于优先考虑此时此地，促使我们追求即时满足，而不是长远利益。
This is a paradox because many of us also believe we want to live lives of continuous improvement. What better way to improve than to listen to suggestions for improvement? What causes so many of us to feel defensive? How can we listen better to feedback and offer feedback in a manner that will be heard? Overcoming defensiveness as a way to improving our lives This week on Hidden Brain We've all been there. Someone pipes up at a work meeting to ask why we were late.
这真是个悖论，因为我们许多人也坚信自己想要过上不断改进的生活。还有什么比听取改进建议更好的改进方式呢？
Or a partner tells us we need to do a better job cleaning up after ourselves. A friend asks why we have to have a asks why we haven't called in a while. Almost effortlessly, the excuses come. The traffic was bad. If the sink was not full of dirty dishes, we would happily wash up our mugs. Did our friend not know that we have been going
或者伴侣告诉我们需要更好地做好事后的清理工作。朋友问我们为什么必须要问为什么好久没打电话了。几乎毫不费力，借口就来了。
through a really difficult time at work? At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Emily Falk studies the science of defensiveness and what we can do about it. Emily Fock, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Emily, you are very close to your grandmother, Bev. Recently, she shared with you her thoughts about the time that you spend with her.
在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家埃米莉·福尔克研究了防御心理的科学以及我们能为此做些什么。埃米莉·福克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Can you paint a picture of what happened that evening, Emily? Yeah, it was a typical night in my house. And what that looks like is one of my kids was jumping up and down on the couch. He was playing his guitar. The other kid was trying to show my grandmother something that he had built. probably a Lego creation, like kind of really, really close up in her face. I was trying to get dinner on the table, so you can imagine sort of dishes clanging, and my phone is probably pinging with emails and text messages from people that I work with
你能描述一下那天晚上发生了什么吗，埃米莉？是的，那是我家里一个普通的夜晚。那情景大概是其中一个孩子在沙发上上下跳跃。他正在弹吉他。
who would really like a response very quickly. And when I was in that situation, I sort of had this sense of like, oh my gosh, there's so many different things that I'm trying to juggle right now. And in that particular moment, I decided that I was going to prioritize a little bit of time with my grandmother. And my grandmother, Bev, is now 100 years old. And she's one of my very favorite people. So she's over at my house for dinner, and I went over to her. I left, you know, the pasta going and handed that over to my partner to handle.
而在那种情况下，我内心有一种感觉：天哪，我现在要同时应付的事情太多了。而在那个特定的时刻，我决定优先花一点时间陪我的祖母。
And I took her hand, and I walked her outside. and sort of in the dusk, I was feeling like a little bit of a sense of relief. Like I was feeling like, okay, we're getting outside. We're getting a little quality time together. And I felt like I had made, you know, the right decision until she turned to me and she said that even though she really liked coming to my house and seeing my kids who are, you know, some of her very favorite people, she said, we aren't really. spending time together. And, you know, it really struck me when she said that because, like, I really didn't want her to be right about that. Like, of course we're spending time together. What do you mean?
我拉着她的手，带她走到户外。在黄昏中，我感到一丝解脱。就像我觉得，好吧，我们出来了。我们有了一些高质量的相处时间。
Like, you're over here. I'm making dinner for all of us. And, you know, we're outside together now. So what do you mean we're not spending time together? Can you just describe what went through your heart as you heard that, Emily? I mean, you're juggling a lot, you're dealing with your kids, you're getting dinner ready, your phone is buzzing, you have calls from work, you're kind enough to have your grandmother over at your place, you're trying to host everyone together, you've taken time out from this incredibly busy and stressful evening to go for a walk outside with your grandmother, and she says you're not doing enough? I definitely initially was like no you're wrong like we do spend time together look what are we doing right now
当你听到这句话时，埃米莉，你能描述一下你内心的感受吗？我的意思是，你要应付很多事情，要照顾孩子，要准备晚餐，手机在震动，有来自工作的电话，
it's the same kind of defensiveness that I feel when you know somebody calls me up and says like why haven't you called me and it's like well we're talking right now what do you want from me so I mean yeah I definitely felt some defensiveness in that moment Can you talk about how common this is, that this is a reaction that we have that I think is such a universal reaction when someone basically gives us feedback about something that we don't want to hear? And this could be somebody in our personal lives. It could be someone in our professional lives. It could be just a casual acquaintance. But our first reaction very often when someone gives us feedback like this is to dig in our heels and say, what are you talking about? Yeah, I think this is an incredibly common experience where, you know, we point out something that somebody could be doing better. Like, for example, you know, maybe your partner could be taking out the trash or your kid could be doing their homework or somebody on your team at work could be responding to your collaborator a little bit more quickly.
这和有人打电话给我说“你为什么不给我打电话”时我感到的防御心理是一样的，感觉就像是：我们现在不是在说话吗？你还想从我这得到什么？
And when we point out these things that we wish other people were doing differently, the things that are most salient for them are all the things that they're already juggling, just like you said. know, with my grandmother, I was juggling a lot of different things having to do with my work and my kids and getting dinner on the table. And those things were front of mind for me. And so when we point out the ways that other people could be improving their health behaviors, you know, choosing healthier activities, quitting smoking, drinking less, getting more exercise, or studying harder, or, you know, making choices that are different than the choices that they're making, that really can feel threatening. It can threaten our self-image. It can threaten our sense that we're making good choices. So you say that defensiveness arises in part because the brain
当我们指出希望别人做出不同行为的事情时，对他们来说最突出的往往是他们已经在应付的所有事情，就像你刚才说的那样。
tends to conflate what is me with what is good. What do you mean by this? I mean that our brain has these systems that help us think about what's good and bad, our value system, and brain systems that help us think about what's me and not me, which I call our self-relevance system. And the self-relevance and value systems are really intertwined with one another. So when we make decisions about what's good and bad, it's tapping into the value system, but that's overlapping with our self-relevance system. And so those kinds of decisions are conflated with one another to the degree that we tend to have these biases where we think of things that are me, typically, on average as being good and things that are not me as being on average bad.
我的意思是，我们的大脑有这些系统来帮助我们思考什么是好与坏，也就是我们的价值系统；还有一些大脑系统帮助我们思考什么是“我”与“非我”，我称之为自我相关系统。
We also have optimism biases where we think of ourselves as being above average, like more than 50% of people think that they're an above average driver. And so when you say, well, you know, you might not be an above average driver. You're actually like pretty risky driver, pretty dangerous driver. People don't say, oh, thank you. Like I'm so glad that you pointed that out. Now I'll go and, like, get some lessons so that I can, you know, be less of a danger to myself and other people on the road. There's the old comedy bit about how people who are driving faster than you are maniacs and people who are driving slower than you are, are, you know, super stodgy.
我们也有乐观偏误，认为自己高于平均水平，比如超过50%的人认为自己的驾驶技术高于平均水平。所以当你指出“你知道，你可能并不是一个高于平均水平的司机”时。
And, of course, you're driving exactly the right speed. So I think what I'm hearing you say, Emily, is that when we're being defensive, you know, it's not just that we're trying to defend our. ourselves against the accusation that we might not be a good driver or a good partner or a good student. In some ways, we feel the attack is on us. Our sense of self is under threat. Exactly. So I think that one of the things that can happen is that when, like, for example, when my grandma told me that she wished that we could spend more time together, and I barely got it together to let her finish her sentence before explaining.
所以我想我听到你这么说，埃米莉，当我们处于防御状态时，你知道，这不仅仅是我们在试图捍卫自己，反驳我们可能不是一个好司机、好伴侣或好学生的指责。
why she was wrong, that it's not just that, you know, I'm thinking about that specific situation of like, are we actually spending quality time together right now or not? But also like, like I said to you earlier, like am I being a good granddaughter, which is an identity that's important to me? Like am I being somebody who shows up for her family in a way that feels good for them? And so this idea that like we cling to. to the idea that we're doing things right is extremely common. Like, there's a New Yorker cartoon, I think, where there's a bunch of guys sitting around a boardroom table,
正如我之前对你说的，比如我是不是一个好孙女？这是一个对我很重要的身份认同。我是一个能以让他们感到舒适的方式支持家庭的人吗？
and the caption is, my last comment appeared to be inviting feedback. Do not be fooled, right? And that's funny because, like, the guy is, you know, maybe he said something like he's interested in feedback, but everybody sitting around the table knows that what he actually wants to hear is that he's doing a great job.
标语是：我刚才的评论似乎是在征求反馈意见。千万别上当，对吧？这很搞笑，因为那家伙，也许他说过他对反馈感兴趣，但坐在桌子周围的每个人都知道，
So if a sense of self that we want to protect is at the heart of defensiveness, one idea to reduce this defensiveness is to make the self less salient or less prominent. You conducted a study that looked at how the practice of self-distancing affected college students' defensiveness when it came to hearing men.
如果你想要保护的自我意识是防御心理的核心，那么减少这种防御心理的一个想法就是让自我变得不那么显眼或不那么突出。你曾做过一项研究，
messages about alcohol. Tell me about that study, Emily. In that study, what we had people do was we had college students who told us on a day-to-day basis about how much they were drinking alcohol. And we randomized people into different conditions. Some of them just reacted naturally to alcohol the whole time. Some of them were given a technique where they took the perspective of another person who is part of their social group who drank less than they did. And so those people on a day-to-day basis were given reminders. Like, let's imagine that you and I are friends and that you drink less than I do. I would get text messages that say, you know, today if you encounter alcohol, you should approach
在这项研究中，我们让那些每天告诉我们自己喝多少酒的大学生参与进来。我们将这些人随机分配到不同的组别中。其中一些人自始至终对酒精做出自然反应。
it the way that Shanker would. And other people were given messages that told them to essentially take a step back and just react in a more mindful way. So basically to have whatever feelings they were having, but to do it from a more distanced perspective. And both of those kinds of tools for creating psychological distance, taking the perspective of another person
其他人则得到了指引，本质上是让他们退后一步，以一种更有意识的方式做出反应。基本上就是去体会他们当时产生的任何感受，但从一个更有距离感的角度去体验。
who drinks less than you do, or reacting in that non-reactive way that characterizes mindfulness, both resulted in people drinking less than on weeks when they, they reacted naturally or compared to people who were reacting naturally. Another way to reduce the dominance of the self and potentially decrease defensiveness is to identify less closely with the characteristics that define us as people.
或者以那种以正念为特征的非反应性方式做出反应，这两者都使得人们的饮酒量比那些自然反应的周数要少，或者与那些自然反应的人相比饮酒量更少。
Researchers have found that when we create a ranking of personal traits, some feel very central to our sense of self while others are more peripheral. How can we use this to reduce defensiveness, Emily? Yeah. So there's this really wonderful research that I like that comes out of Brent Hughes's lab. And what he's done is look at these networks of different kinds of traits and the way that people think of them as relating to each other. And so there are some that are more central. Like, for example, our kindness or our compassion might be traits that we think of as core traits that are at the center of this network. And the traits that kind of depend on those but aren't necessarily our most central traits, like maybe being witty, that those things are a little bit more open to feedback. And so this team of researchers led by Jacob Elder in Brent's lab found that it can be easier for us to incorporate feedback about traits that are more peripheral than our core ones. Like, we really don't want to change the things that we think of as being, like, really, really core to us. So what the team found was that after receiving feedback, people were more willing to update their self-views about peripheral traits.
是的。所以有一项非常棒的研究我很喜欢，它来自布伦特·休斯（Brent Hughes）的实验室。他所做的是研究不同类型特质的网络，以及人们认为这些特质如何相互关联的方式。
Like, one example they gave is well-spoken. People generally don't think of, like, well-spoken as something that's really core to their identity. but if the committee gave feedback that was like this person doesn't seem like they're that friendly, then we might come up with reasons why, like, well, I know that I'm friendly and maybe I was nervous and that didn't really come across in this video, but like I know that that's true about myself. I mean, I'm thinking about the interaction you had with your grandmother Bev. In some ways when she said, you know, we're not spending enough. time together, the message that you're hearing almost instantly is, you know, she's saying
比如，他们给出的一个例子是“口齿伶俐”。人们通常不认为“口齿伶俐”是他们身份的核心部分。
I'm not a good granddaughter, and that is core and central to my identity, and I'm going to fight to defend that because that is who I am. On the other hand, if your grandmother had said something like, I know you're super busy, you really care about me, I know you really want to spend time together with me, but I can see how busy you are and how many different things you're juggling. Is there a way we can, you know, figure out how you can balance your time so that we can spend some quality time together. Now the criticism, to the extent that it is criticism, is just about the fact that Emily is very busy and how do we problem solve, you know, her being less busy so she can spend more time with me. It's not so much a criticism
从某种程度上说，当她说“我们花在一起的时间不够”时，你几乎瞬间听到的信息是，她说我不是个好孙女，
of Emily being a bad granddaughter. In some ways, is that what you're talking about in terms of focusing our efforts to influence someone else on something that might be not a core portion of their identity? Well, it's interesting because I think that, you know, as the receiver of the feedback, we can kind of toggle between those different kinds of states. I think it's really hard to control how other people receive those messages, and we have much more control over how we do, because there's a world where, you know, she says, I'd really like to spend some more quality time with you, and I take that as evidence that she thinks I'm not a good granddaughter, and that's threatening to my core sense of self
这很有趣，因为我认为，作为反馈的接受者，我们可以在这些不同状态之间切换。我认为很难控制别人如何接收这些信息，
and my identity, that maybe I'm not, like, as generous or kind or whatever. whatever, as I could be. But there's also a world where I can do the translation that you're describing and just say, like, oh, let's figure out how we can make this work logistically, right? If I can let go of some of that defensiveness and recognize that this is a goal that I have also to spend time together, then we're both much better off. One of the things that I think we we really do have control over is our ability to decide whether we want to be the kind of person who responds to loving critique, constructive critique openly, or whether we want to let defensiveness get the better of us. And obviously there are situations where people are just mean or rude
我们真正能控制的事情之一就是我们有能力决定，自己是否想成为那种能够公开回应充满爱的批评、建设性批评的人，还是想让防御心理占了上风。
or whatever, and I'm not saying we should put up with that. But that often there is useful information in the feedback that other people are trying to give us and that when we can see that as evidence that they care, when we can see that as evidence that they're trying to work towards some better outcome with us or even just connect with the part of ourself that wants to be continuously improving, that can be more productive than this automatic reaction
或者甚至只是连接我们内心想要不断改进的那部分自我，这可能比这种自动反应更具建设性。我认为这种自动反应可能源于自我与价值的混淆。
that I think probably stems from the conflation of self-in-value. Can you talk a moment about the role that meditation might play in helping us be less defensive? Because as you're talking about, you know, simply listening to what your grandmother was saying, as opposed to listening to the implication of what you thought your grandmother was saying, because in fact your grandmother was not saying that you're a bad granddaughter. She's just saying, I feel like we don't spend enough time together and I'd like to spend more time with you. Can you talk about the role of meditation in helping us in some ways just process the world as it comes to us without layering on our judgments and values on top of it?
你能谈谈冥想在帮助我们减少防御心理方面可能扮演的角色吗？正如你所讨论的，你知道，仅仅去听你祖母在说什么，
Yeah, so one of the things that meditation helps people do is let go of that more bounded notion of self, right? The idea that there's a fixed sense of who I am and that that can't change or that it has a particular and rigid structure. So when you look at the brains of people who have practiced meditation for a long time, their self-relevant systems behave differently than the rest of us who aren't long-term meditation practitioners. And so that also really suggests this other possibility that just kind of letting go of that bounded notion of self
是的，所以冥想帮助人们做的事情之一，就是放下那种更有界限的自我概念，对吧？也就是那种认为“我是谁”是固定不变的、
can make us open to all kinds of other possibilities. So far we've been talking to all kinds of other possibilities. talking about reducing defensiveness by making the self smaller, in a sense by shrinking its footprint. But we can also become less defensive by making the self bigger and more multifaceted. When we come back, how enlarging the self can help us keep our minds open. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Emily Falk is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Pennsylvania.
到目前为止，我们一直在讨论通过缩小自我来减少防御心理，从某种意义上说，就是缩小自我的足迹。但我们也可以通过让自我变得更大、更多面来减少防御心理。
She studies why we are often resistant to change and the role of defensiveness in keeping us from making change in our lives. Emily, you say that one of the ways we can reduce defensiveness is by reminding ourselves of what really matters to us and remembering how many aspects of our lives actually do carry this sense of importance. Talk about the practice of values affirmation and how it can help us avoid becoming defensive in the face of threats. Values affirmation is a technique where we reflect on values that matter a lot to us, so things that bring us a lot of meaning or purpose in our lives, which for some of us might be things like our friends and family or our spirituality or maybe our creativity. And the idea is that when we reflect on those core values, it can allow us to zoom out and see that just because we made a mistake, it doesn't have to mean we're a bad person or just because somebody's asking us to change one thing doesn't mean that like everything about us has to change. And so this is a way that we can hold on to a core sense of self while making ourselves more open. to potentially changing things that aren't working
价值观肯定是一种反思对我们非常重要的价值观的技术，也就是那些为我们的生活带来很多意义或目标的事物，对于我们中的一些人来说，
or to kind of shift preconceived notions about who we are. So as one example, our team has done research looking at folks who are relatively sedentary, people who don't move around a lot. And what we found is that when we randomized people to either get to do a values affirmation exercise, reflecting on these kinds of sources of meaning and purpose in their life, things that really matter to them first,
与对照组相比，对照组虽然也反思价值观，但反思的并非他们最重要的价值观，所发生转变的是他们的大脑对接下来发生的事情的反应方式。
compared to a control group who reflect on values but the ones that aren't necessarily their most important values, that what shifts is how their brains respond to the thing that comes next. So when we give those folks coaching about why and how they might want to get more physically active, everybody in the whole study is seeing the same coaching messages. So things like the more you sit, the more damage it does to your body, or according to the American Heart Association, people at your level of physical and activity are at risk for cancer and heart disease.
所以当我们给这些人提供关于他们为什么以及如何想要变得更有身体活动能力的指导时，研究中的所有人看到的都是相同的指导信息。
And even though everybody's seeing objectively the same messages, the people who were first given this chance to engage in values affirmation show more activation within the brain's value system, more activation within the self-relevant system, suggesting that maybe they're open to those messages in a different way than people who weren't given that opportunity to first zoom out and reflect on their core values. How do you employ this technique in your own life, Emily?
尽管每个人看到的客观上都是相同的信息，但那些首先获得机会进行价值观肯定的人，表现出更多的大脑价值系统激活，
Do you try and reflect on your own values if you know you're about to hear some feedback that is going to be difficult? Yeah, well, I mean, I think it also depends how you think about what difficult means. Like right now we're in performance review season at Penn. And, you know, something that we do in my lab is we do a bidirectional feedback meeting. Like we fill out the HR forums where it's very top down. Like as a manager, I need to give feedback to all the people who report to me. But in that HR system, there's actually no place where they give feedback about what I'm doing,
好，嗯，我的意思是，我认为这也取决于你如何看待“困难”意味着什么。就像现在是宾夕法尼亚大学的绩效考核季。
well and what I'm not doing well. And so we have these meetings that I know are on my calendar. I know it's about to be the time when I'm going to be giving feedback to somebody else, but also they're going to be telling me what did I do as their boss over the past semester, over the past year that was helpful for them and helped them grow, but also what did I do as their boss that they wished I had done differently? And there are a couple different things. Like one is when I have the luxury of a little bit of time in my schedule. I do try to do a little bit of that kind of mini values affirmation, like reflecting on things that actually really matter a lot to me. So I might like look at photos of my kids or journal a little bit about, you know, things that I feel grateful for
我会试着看一些我孩子的照片，或者写一点日记，记录下我感激的事情以及我生活中最重要的事情。
and things that are most important in my life. But I also try to like reconnect with why we're doing what we're doing in the first place. And then the way that we set up these bi-directional feedback meetings is we usually start out with the things that are going well, right? The things where they really genuinely do feel supported, the places that were really connected, the places that we're on the same page. And I will say that when people do this genuinely and authentically, it feels really good, like to feel seen and to feel recognized for the things that we're doing that are meaningful. Like, it feels, um, different than the way that we engage when we're busy in our day-to-day lives, right?
有了这个基础，听到建设性的批评或建设性的意见就让人觉得是可以接受的了。就像我想起去年我团队里的一位资深员工告诉我，
And so having that foundation, then it feels possible to hear the constructive criticism or the constructive critique. Like, I'm thinking about one of the senior folks on my team last year told me that it felt really demotivating when it took me a long time to get papers back to her. Like, she would work really hard to put a paper in my writing queue, and then because of whatever else I had going on in my life, like, sometimes it would take me weeks to give her feedback. And she said, you know, when I do that, I lose steam. It makes me feel like unmotivated to keep the process going. And, you know, there's kind of like with the situation with Bev, there's an interpretation of that, which is like, oh, like, look at my calendar. Like, I have meetings all day
我知道这对于她来说非常重要，所以我可以优先处理。这真的很好。我团队里的另一位资深员工告诉我，
long. And you are one of many people who wants my feedback, right? And so I think there's a way that it feels very easy to respond defensively there. But there's also something that's really valuable about the feedback that she's giving me, which is like we both have a goal to share the research that we're doing with other people. And I certainly don't want to be the bottleneck in that process, and especially if it's going to feel demotivating for her. So, you know, over the past year, I've tried to think with her together about how we might plan and schedule so that I know.
所以我今年一直在努力保护更多的时间来和那个人开会，而且你知道，这又是双向绩效反馈的时间了，她还是说：
when these things are going to be coming into my writing queue and that I can turn them around more quickly, right? If I know that that's something that's really important to her, I can prioritize it. And that's been really good. Another senior person on my team, you know, told me that she felt like it was sometimes hard to get meeting time with me and that she felt like it was, you know, she didn't want to impose basically and that that felt really hard that like since I was clearly, you know, running around and doing so many different things
所以我猜我只是不想粉饰太平，好像我们做了这一件事，然后所有问题都解决了吧。但我认为我的目标是带着这样的想法去参加这些会议：
and juggling them and sharing that with her, that it felt like maybe she shouldn't take time in our meetings to like catch up about our weekends or maybe she shouldn't take time to, you know, get into the weeds of little things that weren't the most pressing things. and so this year I've worked on trying to protect more time to meet with that person and you know it's bidirectional performance feedback time again and she's like
所以你还发现，感受到意义和目标感也可以扩展我们的自我意识，使我们在面对具有挑战性的信息时防御性更低。为什么会这样，埃米莉？目标和意义扮演了什么角色？
it's a little bit better but I still feel that way sometimes and so you know I I guess I just don't want to like paint this picture like we do this one thing and then everything's fixed but I think that my goal is to go into those meetings thinking about how we can work together to make things a little bit better each time. So you've also found that feeling a sense of meaning and purpose can also expand our sense of self and make us less defensive in the face of challenging information. How so, Emily. What role do purpose and meaning play? Well, so purpose has all kinds of benefits.
所以，目标感有很多各种各样的好处。目标感，有很多研究强调了目标感如何能让我们对建设性的批评更加开放，就像我们在这里谈论的那样。
Purpose, there's a lot of research that highlights how purpose can make us more open to constructive feedback like we're talking about here. It can also make us more likely to engage in behaviors that are good for our body. Like there's a reciprocal relationship between things like getting a good night sleep or going for a walk. or connecting with people that we love and a sense of purpose. So when we do those things that are good for our bodies, we can feel more purposeful later. And then when we feel more purposeful, it makes it more likely that we'll do those things.
并且我认为其中一件需要强调的重要事情有时我们会认为某些人更有目标感，比如特蕾莎修女，超级有目标感，对吧？
And I think that an important thing to highlight there is that sometimes I think we think of some people as being more purposeful, like Mother Teresa, super purposeful, right? But in reality, most of us fluctuate on a day-to-day basis around some set point, like we have our average, but some days we feel more purposeful, some days we feel less purposeful. And on those days where we feel more purposeful, maybe because we reflected on the things that really matter to us, or maybe we took the time to go for a walk around the block or to call our best friend on the phone, that that has all these other benefits as
你能谈谈其实也存在不同种类的目标感吗？所以，比如说，我可以把我的目标说成是变得非常富有，我想要听取你的反馈，
well. Can you talk about how there are also different kinds of purpose? So, for example, you know, I can say my purpose is to become very wealthy and I want to listen to your feedback and perhaps not feel defensive about your feedback because in some ways your feedback could help me in my goal of becoming very wealthy. But research has also found that when a sense of purpose involves self-transcendant values, it tends to be more effective in diminishing defensiveness. Can you talk about this work, Emily? So when we had people do a values, affirmation exercise where they ranked different values that might be important to them. As you said, some people choose values that are these self-transcendent values that connect them
当我们让人做价值观肯定练习时，他们会对自己可能认为重要的不同价值观进行排序。正如你所说，有些人选择这些能够将他们连接到更大整体的自我超越价值观，
to a bigger whole, to people or, you know, a world that's bigger than myself. And when people tend to endorse these self-transcendent values more as composed of more self-focused values, that they show lower reactivity in brain regions that track threat. So it seems like getting those kinds of health coaching messages when they have this other psychological resource of self-transcendent values to rely on, that that incoming information might be less threatening. I understand that one other way to expand our sense of self and reduce defensive reactions is to have what psychologists call transformative experiences, you know, like going to Burning Man, for example. Tell me about these experiences. How do you
当我了解到，扩展自我意识和减少防御反应的另一种方法是进行心理学家所说的“变革性体验”，你知道，比如去参加“火人节”，等等。请跟我讲讲这些体验。
How do they work and why would they affect defensiveness, Emily? Yeah, so this is research that I really love. The idea is that there are certain kinds of experiences that we have that can be relatively transformative experiences that often involve kind of letting go, again, of that bounded sense of self and seeing the way that we're connected to something much bigger than ourselves. So something that connects us to other people, to the rest of humanity. And so this can happen through meditation. It can happen when people take psychedelic drugs.
它们是如何起作用的，为什么会影响防御心理呢，艾米丽？是的，所以这是我非常喜欢的一项研究。这个想法是，我们拥有的某些经历可以成为相对变革性的经历，这些经历通常涉及再次放下那种界限分明的自我意识，并看到我们与比自己大得多的事物相连的方式。因此，有些东西将我们与其他人、与全人类联系在一起。所以这可以通过冥想发生。当人们服用迷幻药时也会发生这种情况。
It can happen through rituals where people come together and do things. So like you mentioned, Burning Man. And my friend and fellow neuroscientist, Molly Crockett, has explored how these kinds of transformative experiences are characterized really by an expansion, an expanded sense of self. And so going to festivals like Burning Man and studying how people think and feel and behave in those kinds of contexts, Molly's team has found that those kinds of transformative experiences often involve having more of a sense of connection to other people, more of a sense of not having a bounded sense of me and not me that our brains are typically and sort of more automatically generating. So when people do these kinds of things where they're connected to their community or experiencing community in a really different way, then that can help them let go of that, like, sense of ego that sometimes, I think, is characteristic of the defensiveness that we feel.
这种情况可以通过人们聚集在一起并共同做事的仪式来实现。就像你提到的那样，火人节。我的朋友兼神经科学家同行莫莉·克罗克特（Molly Crockett）探讨了这些变革性体验的特征，即自我意识的极大扩展。因此，通过去参加像火人节这样的节日，研究人们在那种情境下的所思所想、所感所行，莫莉的团队发现，这类变革性体验往往会让人觉得与他人有了更深的连接，减少了大脑通常会自动产生的“我和非我”这种界限感。所以，当人们参与这类活动，与社区产生连接，或者以一种非常不同的方式体验社区时，这有助于他们放下那种自我意识，而我认为，这种自我意识有时正是我们感受到的防御性的特征。
We've looked at two different ways of working with our self-image in order to reduce defensiveness, to make the self-smaller, and to make the self bigger. In addition to these approaches, we can also shift the way we engage with the information that makes us uncomfortable. When we come back, how to put a different spin on information that we would otherwise want to shut out.
我们已经探讨了通过两种不同的方式来调整自我形象，以减少防御性：一种是让自我变小，另一种是让自我变大。除了这些方法之外，我们还可以改变自己对待那些让我们感到不适的信息的方式。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何对那些我们原本想排斥的信息赋予不同的视角。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist and neuroscientist Emily Falk studies why we fail to change and how we can do better. A central focus of her work has been on examining the role of defensiveness, the way we shut down feedback by digging in our heels. If you have follow-up questions or thoughts for Emily
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家兼神经科学家埃米莉·福尔克（Emily Falk）研究了我们为什么无法改变以及我们如何才能做得更好。她的核心研究重点之一是审视防御性的作用，即我们如何通过固执己见来关闭反馈。如果您对埃米莉有任何后续问题或想法
after listening to today's conversation and you're willing to share your thoughts with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, mental barriers. That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Emily, your research has found that people often react defensively to direct appeals to change their behavior, but they respond quite differently to the same information when it's presented in story form. Why would this be the case?
在听完今天的对话后，如果您愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享您的想法，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请填写：心理障碍。再重复一遍邮箱地址：Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。埃米莉，您的研究发现，人们对直接呼吁改变行为的诉求往往会产生防御性反应，但如果将相同的信息以故事的形式呈现，他们的反应则会完全不同。为什么会这样呢？
Well, one of the things that's really fascinating is the way that stories seem to get around our defensiveness. We see this in all kinds of situations where people are able to reason about facts and information in a different way when it comes from a story than when it's just presented as a list of facts. And I noticed this a lot as a parent. when my kids were little, I read an article summarizing some research about the way that Inuit parents sometimes use stories to help teach children how to control their anger. And that work highlighted all of the different, you know, ways that stories can be used to shape our understanding of morality, our understanding of, you know, how we should behave. And, And I also saw it on a day-to-day basis in my household. So I have twins. And the twins often would get into like very hyped up states with each other where they'd be fighting over a toy or they'd be fighting over who got to wear the blue pajamas or they would be fighting over, you know, who got to go first to get into the bathtub. And any of these things seemed like just very dire, steaksy situations. And, you know, when I would have to go first to get into the bathtub. And, you know, when I would.
嗯，最吸引人的地方之一在于，故事似乎能够绕过我们的防御性。我们在各种情况下都能看到这一点：当事实和信息来自一个故事时，人们能够以一种与单纯作为事实列表呈现时不同的方式来对它们进行推理。作为一名父母，我对此深有体会。在我的孩子们还小的时候，我读过一篇文章，总结了一些研究，内容是因纽特父母有时如何利用故事来帮助孩子学会控制愤怒。那项工作突显了故事可以被用来塑造我们的道德理解、塑造我们对“我们应该如何行为”的理解的各种方式。而且，我在日常生活中也从自己的家庭中看到了这一点。我有双胞胎。双胞胎经常会陷入非常情绪高涨的状态，比如为一件玩具争吵，或者为谁能穿蓝色睡衣争吵，再或者为谁能第一个进浴缸洗澡而争吵。所有这些事情在他们看来都像是生死攸关的重大事件。而且，当我不得不……
ask them like, guys, like, can you please just calm down or what's going on? Like, why are you behaving this way? Like, that didn't have any effect at all. But when I would ask them, would you like to hear a story, then sometimes they would pause and listen. And we had two characters in our house, Charlie and Charles Adams, named after the cartoonist who we all like. And when we'd tell stories about Charlie and Charles Adams, then we'd get a completely different reaction. The kids would be able to suggest ways that Charlie and Charles Adams could very generously share the toy or, you know, take turns wearing the special pajamas or, you know, take turns getting into the bath first. And then after they had stopped and reasoned about it for those other people, then we were able to say,
对他们说，嘿，孩子们，能不能请你们冷静一点？或者到底怎么回事？你们为什么会有这种行为？——那样做完全没有任何效果。但如果我问他们：“你们想听一个故事吗？”他们有时就会停下来听。我们家里有两个角色，查理（Charlie）和查尔斯·亚当斯（Charles Adams），这是以我们都很喜欢的漫画家名字命名的。当我们讲述关于查理和查尔斯·亚当斯的故事时，我们就会得到完全不同的反应。孩子们会能够提出各种建议，比如查理和查尔斯·亚当斯可以如何非常慷慨地分享玩具，或者轮流穿着那件特殊的睡衣，或者轮流第一个进浴室。然后，在他们停下来为其他人进行推理之后，我们就可以说：
well, do you think that you guys could do any of those things? And sometimes it would work. And, you know, this came up the other day with my neighbor. I was over at my neighbor's house and two of their kids were having a little bit of a tussle. And I said, hey, guys, you know what happens when Emmett and Theo are in this situation? And just, you know, tell a situation that's very similar to the one that's playing out there. And then these little humans whose prefrontal cortex isn't fully developed can still reason in a completely reasonable way. And what do you think is happening? Because as you're telling me this, I'm reflecting on how when I listen to a story, it suddenly pulls me out of this mode of do I agree or do I disagree and puts me into a mode of like,
“嗯，你们觉得你们也能做到这些事情吗？”有时这确实管用。而且，你知道的，前几天我的邻居也遇到了这种情况。我在邻居家里，他们的两个孩子发生了一点小争执。我说：“嘿，孩子们，你们知道当埃米特（Emmett）和西奥（Theo）遇到这种情况下会发生什么吗？”然后，你知道的，讲一个与他们正在经历的事情非常相似的情境。接着，这些前额叶皮层尚未完全发育的小人类，依然能够以一种完全合情合理的方式进行推理。你觉得发生了什么？因为当你在告诉我这些时，我正在反思：当我听一个故事时，它突然把我从“我是否同意”或“我是否反对”的模式中拉了出来，并把我带入了这样一种模式：
let me try and understand what's happening inside these different perspectives. And suddenly, I'm now analytical, I'm observant, I'm not defensive. Yeah. And researchers who study narrative persuasion call that experience transportation, being transported into a story. We can identify with the characters in a different way than when we're experiencing things ourselves. And research in the brain that our team has done shows that there's fundamentally different pathways that are unfolding when we're reasoning about stories and other kinds of facts. So we had smokers who came into the lab and we used this brain stimulation technique called transcranial direct current stimulation, which temporarily disrupts the function of certain
让我试着去理解这些不同视角内部正在发生的事情。突然之间，我变得善于分析、善于观察，而且不再具有防御性。是的。研究叙事说服力的研究人员将这种体验称为“沉浸”（transported），即被带入一个故事中。与我们自己亲身经历事情时相比，我们可以用一种不同的方式与角色产生共鸣。我们的团队在大脑上进行的研究表明，当我们对故事和其他类型的事实进行推理时，展开的是根本不同的神经通路。因此，我们让吸烟者来到实验室，并使用了一种名为“经颅直流电刺激”的脑刺激技术，它可以暂时干扰某些脑区的
brain regions. And so we used it to temporarily disrupt regions that typically are involved in that kind of effortful thinking. And when people were getting their brain stimulated using this technology, and they were given didactic facts, things like, you know, if you smoke for 30 years, it increases your risk of lung cancer by X percent, then when we disrupted the function of these brain regions, it made it so that they were less able to reason about those facts compared to when we use sham stimulation where they're hooked up to the machine,
大脑区域的功能。因此，我们用它来暂时干扰通常参与那种需要努力思考的脑区。当人们使用这项技术接受大脑刺激，并被赋予说教式的事实——比如，如果你吸烟30年，它会将你患肺癌的风险提高X个百分点——时，一旦我们干扰了这些脑区的功能，与使用假性刺激（即他们连接到机器上，但实际上并没有干扰那些脑区）相比，他们对这些事实进行推理的能力就会下降。
but not actually having those brain regions disrupted. On the other hand, for people, for the smokers who came into the lab and did the same procedure, but they were given stories, even when we disrupted the function of these brain regions that we typically think of as being key for our ability to reason, they could still generate just as many arguments and think about what was happening. So being told John smoked for 30 years and he developed lung cancer, they were able to reason about it in a different way. And I think part of what's happening there is that other brain systems are being called into use.
另一方面，对于来到实验室并经历相同程序的吸烟者，但给他们提供的是故事，即使我们干扰了那些我们通常认为对推理能力至关重要的脑区的功能，他们仍然能够产生同样多的论点并思考正在发生的事情。因此，当被告知“约翰吸烟30年并患上了肺癌”时，他们能够以一种不同的方式对此进行推理。我认为其中一部分原因在于，其他的大脑系统被调用并投入使用了。
So we know from other research that social relevance brain systems that help us understand what other people think and feel are engaged when we hear stories. when we tell stories, and that that kind of thinking might be fundamentally different from the other kinds of reasoning that we're talking about. So you've hinted at this idea in different ways, Emily, but when we think about the challenges we have from the perspective of someone who is not us, it dramatically changes the way we think about the perspectives that we have. So in other words, when your kids hear the story about these other kids who are dealing with a problem, all of a sudden it's not personal in a way. They have the latitude, the freedom, to say, what is the course of options that are open to these other people?
我们从其他研究中得知，当我们听到故事、讲述故事时，帮助我们理解他人想法和感受的“社会相关性”大脑系统会被激活，并且这种思维方式可能与我们正在讨论的其他类型的推理有着根本的不同。埃米莉，你已经以不同的方式暗示过这个想法了，但当我们从一个不是我们自己的视角来思考我们所面临的挑战时，它彻底改变了我们看待自身视角的方式。换句话说，当你的孩子听到关于其他孩子如何处理问题的故事时，突然之间，这在某种程度上就不再是私人的了。他们拥有了广阔的空间和自由去说：“对其他人来说，有哪些可选的方案呢？”
And when you're in the position of being the advice giver rather than the advice getter, it changes the way you think about the advice. Exactly. And research by folks like Ethan Cross, some of the research that's been done here at Penn in the Behavior Change for Good initiative shows exactly that, that when people are put in the position of either taking the perspective of a distanced other person, like the perspective of a fly on the wall or the perspective of somebody else or the perspective of someone giving advice to another person, that that makes it easier. for us to actually think about the situation in a more wise way ourself. And so we can come up with better solutions. We can come up with wiser solutions. And I'll say personally, the number of studies that I've run where I have tried to convince somebody else to do something to get more physically active or use sunscreen or floss or whatever it is, and then I just end up convincing myself, like I'm just this constellation of all the studies that I've ever run. Because for so many years I've been doing these studies trying to convince other people to do stuff.
当你处于给予建议者的位置，而不是接受建议者的位置时，它会改变你对建议的看法。确切地说。像伊森·克罗斯（Ethan Cross）这样的人的研究——宾夕法尼亚大学“促进良好行为倡议”（Behavior Change for Good）这里所做的一些研究——正好表明了这一点：当人们被置于采取一个有距离的他人视角的位置时，比如墙上的一只苍蝇的视角，或者其他某个人的视角，或者是向另一个人提供建议的人的视角，这会让我们更容易自己以一种更明智的方式来思考情况。因此，我们可以想出更好的解决方案。我们可以想出更明智的解决方案。我可以说，就我个人而言，我做过很多研究，试图说服别人做一些事情，比如变得更加积极运动、使用防晒霜、使用牙线等等，结果我最后却把自己给说服了——我就是我做过的所有研究的集合体。因为多年来我一直在做这些研究，试图说服别人去做事情。
You once ran a study where you asked college students to take the perspective of a peer who had different habits when it came to drinking alcohol. In some ways, you found that that was an effective way of getting through to someone who might not have wanted to hear the message if it was directed at that. Yeah, we ran a study where we had college students get messages on a day-to-day basis. We sent them text messages, and some of the students got messages where they were just told to respond to alcohol, however they normally would. And others were told to take the perspective of somebody who we knew from prior surveys that we had done with them was somebody that they were friends with and drank less than they did.
你曾经做过一项研究，要求大学生站在一个在饮酒习惯上与他们不同的同龄人的角度去思考。在某些方面，你发现这是一种有效的方法，能够触及那些如果消息直接针对他们可能不想听的人。是的，我们进行了一项研究，让大学生每天接收信息。我们给他们发送短信，其中一些学生收到的信息是，被告知像往常一样对酒精做出反应。而另一些学生则被告知要采取一个朋友的视角——根据我们之前对他们进行的调查，我们知道那是他们的一个朋友，而且这个朋友的饮酒量比他们少。
So it's somebody where they're familiar with that behavior and taking the perspective of a friend who drank less than they did also reduced their own drinking. Emily, I understand that your partner made a request of you recently that led you to feel a bit defensive. Can you set the scene for me, please?
所以这是一个他们熟悉其行为的人，而站在饮酒量比自己少的朋友的角度上思考，也减少了他们自己的饮酒量。埃米莉，据我了解，你的伴侣最近对你提出了一个要求，让你感到有些防御性。请问你能为我还原一下当时的情景吗？
What were you and Brett doing at the time? well in the hour or so after my kids go to bed it's a really nice time where brett and i usually hang out with each other and usually we hang out in the kitchen and we clean up from the day and by we clean up from the day i mean brett cleans up from the day and i hang out with him while that happens um which is really a lovely characteristic to have in a partner somebody who's just as happy doing dishes as sitting around and so in this particular evening, Brett was doing his wonderful typical thing of doing the dishes, and I was sitting in a very comfortable chair checking my email. And there was a student who needed something from me in order to be able to move ahead with a project. And I was trying to get back to them quickly because that's something that I like to do. I don't want to be the bottleneck. And as I was on my phone doing this task. Brett said to me that it was really frustrating for him when he felt like, you know, this is time when we're supposed to be hanging out together, and I'm on my phone.
当时你和布雷特（Brett）在做什么？嗯，在孩子们上床睡觉后的大约一个小时里，这是一段非常美好的时光，我和布雷特通常会在一起闲逛，通常我们会待在厨房里收拾一天下来的残局。而“收拾一天下来的残局”的意思是，布雷特在收拾，而我在旁边陪着他——嗯，作为一个伴侣，这真的是一个非常可爱的特质，有人愿意洗碗就像坐在那儿闲聊一样开心。所以在那个特定的晚上，布雷特正在做他那美妙的典型事情——洗碗，而我则坐在一个非常舒服的椅子上检查电子邮件。当时有一个学生需要我提供一些东西，以便能够推进一个项目。我正试图尽快回复他们，因为这是我喜欢做的事情。我不想成为瓶颈。就在我拿着手机做这件事的时候，布雷特对我说，当他觉得这是我们本该一起相处的时间，而我却在玩手机时，他感到非常沮丧。
And, you know, I definitely felt defensive in that moment. Like, there are all kinds of good reasons why I'm on my phone, right? One of the things that you love about me is that I'm a good boss and I'm a good collaborator and I'm a good scientist. And like, this is just going to take a second. And it's not really disrupting the conversation and I can still hear what you're saying and do you want me to just recite back to you exactly what you just said and of course like that did not interest Brett like there's research that highlights that when other people are on their phones it's annoying right like it's super annoying and in the moment I was defensive I was not prepared to concede that of course he was right but you know as I thought about it over the next couple of
而且，你知道的，那一刻我确实感到了防御性。比如，我玩手机有各种各样的好理由，对吧？你喜欢我的地方之一就是我是一个好老板、一个好合作者、一个好科学家。而且，这只需要花一秒钟。这并没有真正打扰我们的谈话，我仍然能听到你在说什么，难道你想让我把刚才说的话一字不差地背诵给你听吗？当然，这种态度对布雷特来说毫无吸引力——有研究强调，当别人在玩手机时，这是很烦人的，对吧？——这超级烦人。但在当时的那一刻，我有防御心理。我还没有准备好承认他是对的，但是，你知道的，当我在接下来的几天里思考这件事时……
of days, because Brett is also, like, not really one to complain that much. It's rare that he says to me, like, I really don't like what you're doing. I need you to change something. And so even that sort of subtle, like, it feels really bad for me when you're on your phone when we're hanging out. That was noticeable. And so over the next couple of days, I started thinking about, you know, who do I actually want to be in this situation? And I started thinking about the people in our lives where you go over to their house and you don't even know if they have a cell phone, right? Like they are definitely not checking their email or their texts and how different that feels from, you know, the person who every time you bring something up, they're like, let me just fact check that. And they like go on their phone, beep, boep, and like, you know, give you whatever stats or show you a YouTube video or something like that rarely adds to the conversation, right?
因为布雷特也是那种不怎么抱怨的人。他很少对我说：“我真的不喜欢你做的事。我需要你改变某些地方。”因此，哪怕是那种含蓄的表达——“当你和我们在一起却在玩手机时，我感觉非常糟糕”——也是非常明显的。所以在接下来的几天里，我开始思考：在这场冲突中，我究竟想成为一个怎样的人？我开始想到我们生活中的那些人：你去他们家做客，甚至不知道他们是否有手机，对吧？他们绝对不会去查看电子邮件或短信，与那种“你每次提起一件事，他们就说‘让我查个事实’，然后掏出手机‘哔、波’地给你查各种数据或者给你看YouTube视频”的人相比，这种感觉有多么不同——而那往往无助于对话，对吧？
and so thinking about those people in my life who are so present in those interactions felt really motivating for me and I thought like that's actually how I want to be when I'm with Brett and so I tried to make some environmental shifts like leaving my phone in the other room when we're hanging out and that works for the most part I'll say I'm not perfect I felt a little caught out the other night. It was that hour after the kids went to bed and I was texting with a friend and she had just finished reading my book
因此，想到我生命中那些在互动中全身心投入的人，让我感到非常有动力，我想：“这其实就是我和布雷特在一起时想成为的样子。”所以我试图做出一些环境上的改变，比如我们在闲逛时把手机留在另一个房间里，这在很大程度上是管用的。我得说我并不完美，前几天晚上我还是觉得有点被抓包了。那是孩子们上床睡觉后的一个小时，我正在和一个朋友发短信，她刚刚读完我讲述这个故事的书。
where I tell this story. And she was like, aren't you supposed to be hanging out with Brett right now? Why are you texting with me? And I was like, oh my gosh. So then I was like double defensive. Like I know that I'm supposed to be hanging out with Brett. Brett's probably like a little bit annoyed
她说：“你现在不是应该在陪布雷特吗？你为什么在和我发短信？”当时我就想：“哦，天哪！”于是我产生了双重防御心理。一方面我知道自己应该在陪布雷特，布雷特可能对这种情况有点恼火……
about the situation. And now my friend is probably judging me that, like, of course, I just told everybody that I want to be doing this. And yet, that is the person I want to be. So I was like, you're totally right. Took the phone, put it somewhere else. And so I really appreciated that she called me out on that. Emily Falk is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Pennsylvania.
而现在我的朋友可能也在评判我，觉得我明明刚告诉所有人我想成为那种人，结果却……尽管如此，这确实是我想要成为的人。所以我说：“你完全说得对。”然后我拿起手机，把它放到了别的地方。所以，我真的很感激她当场指出了这一点。埃米莉·福尔克是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家和神经科学家。
She's the author of What We Value, the Neuroscience of Choice and Change. Emily, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Yeah, thank you for having me, Shankar. It's such a pleasure. Do you have follow-up questions or thoughts for Emily that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience? If so, please find a quiet room. and record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line,
她著有《我们珍视什么：选择与改变的神经科学》（What We Value, the Neuroscience of Choice and Change）。埃米莉，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。是的，谢谢你邀请我，尚卡尔。这真是太荣幸了。您对埃米莉有任何后续问题或想法，愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享吗？如果是这样，请找一个安静的房间。
Mental Barriers. That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. When we come back, our latest edition of your questions answered. We'll discuss listeners' thoughts and questions on memory with psychologist Kira Green. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain.
并在手机上录制语音备忘录，然后发送至Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请填写：心理障碍。再重复一遍邮箱地址：Ideas@Hiddenbrain.org。稍后回来，我们将为您带来“解答您的疑问”最新期。我们将与心理学家基拉·格林（Kira Green）一起探讨听众关于记忆的想法和问题。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Cast your mind back to a day last week. Let's say Thursday. What did you eat for dinner that day? What clothes were you wearing? Who were you with? And what did you chat about? Drawing a blank?
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回想一下上周的某一天，比如星期四。那天你晚饭吃了什么？你穿着什么衣服？你和谁在一起？你们聊了些什么？脑子里一片空白吗？
You're not alone. We tend to think that we should remember what happens in our lives, and when we forget details, we berate ourselves treating our memory lapses like flaws. Psychologist Kira Green studies the science of memory and forgetting. We recently talked with her on the show. That episode is titled, Forget About It. Today, Kira returns to the show to answer your questions about memory and forgetfulness. Kira Green, welcome back to Hidden Brain.
你并不孤单。我们往往认为自己应该记住生活中发生的事情，而当我们忘记细节时，我们会责备自己，把记忆空白当作缺点。心理学家基拉·格林研究记忆与遗忘的科学。我们最近在节目中采访了她。那一期的标题是《忘了吧》。今天，基拉重返节目，回答你们关于记忆和健忘的问题。基拉·格林，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me again. Kura, as I remember from our previous conversation, you see that most of us think that forgetting is the opposite of remembering. What's wrong with looking at things that way? Well, I suppose the problem with it really is that it makes us think about memory as though it's along a continuum of accuracy, that, you know, what we're aiming for is kind of top-level accuracy. So remembering something is good, not remembering something is bad.
谢谢再次邀请我。基拉，正如我从我们之前的对话中记得的，你认为我们大多数人认为遗忘是记住的反义词。这样看待问题有什么不对呢？嗯，我想这里真正的问题在于，它让我们把记忆当作沿着准确度连续体存在的东西，你知道的，我们的目标是某种顶级准确度。所以记住某些东西是好的，不记住某些东西是坏的。
And I think that's the way a lot of us tend to think about memory, that, you know, it's about achieving that accuracy, getting that thing right. But actually, you know, we're not computers. It's not a matter of retrieving something and you either retrieve it correctly, in which case you get a nice big checkmark, or you don't retrieve it and then it's a big X and you've done something wrong. And we're actually reconstructing our memories actively all the time. A lot of people have this metaphor that memory is like a filing system, you know, either like a filing cabinet or on a computer. and that you should just be able to go in and pull out the file and retrieve it and it's right there. But we're not doing that. We're actively constructing the memory. And then when we do that during the process of that construction, not all the details are exactly the way they will
我想这也是我们许多人倾向于看待记忆的方式，你知道的，这是关于实现准确性，把事情搞对。但实际上，你知道的，我们不是计算机。这不仅仅是检索某样东西，要么你正确检索了，在这种情况下你会得到一个漂亮的勾，要么你没有检索，然后就是一个大叉，你做错了什么。事实上，我们一直在积极地重新构建我们的记忆。很多人有一种隐喻，认为记忆就像一个文件系统，你知道的，就像一个文件柜或计算机上的系统，你应该能够直接进去调出文件并检索它，它就在那里。但我们并不是在那样做。我们是在积极地构建记忆。然后当我们在这个构建过程中这样做时，并不是所有的细节都和它们最初
originally have been. We'll sort of construct it in a more kind of schematic way that will give us the gist, the important parts of what's there. And through that process of reconstruction, what we're doing is pulling out the bits of memory that are important to us and letting the parts that aren't important to us or aren't relevant to a particular situation drift away. What we call remembering and forgetting are actually part of that same process of constructing a memory along particular lines that includes some details and doesn't include others. Remembering absolutely every detail isn't necessarily something that we should want.
完全一样。我们会以一种更具图式化的方式构建它，为我们提供本质，即那里重要的部分。通过这个重建过程，我们所做的是提取对我们重要的记忆片段，而让那些对我们不重要或与特定情境不相关的部分飘走。我们所谓的记住和遗忘实际上是沿着特定路线构建记忆的同一过程的一部分，其中包括一些细节，而不包括其他细节。记住绝对每一个细节不一定是我们应该想要的东西。
And sometimes we actually need to forget. And one of the things that forgetting allows us to do is to kind of prune away all the unnecessary aspects of memories so that we can remember the jimmy. of our day-to-day lives and kind of pull together and observe patterns across all of our experiences. So in your research, Kira, you make a distinction between things that are important for us to remember and things that are not. So, for example, it might not matter in the long run if I remember where I left my keys, but I do want to remember my college graduation or my
有时我们实际上需要遗忘。遗忘让我们做的事情之一就是修剪掉记忆中所有不必要的方面，这样我们就能记住日常生活的精髓，并将我们所有的经验汇集和观察模式。所以在你的研究中，基拉，你在对我们来说重要需要记住的事情和不重要的事情之间做了区分。例如，从长远来看，我是否记得把钥匙放在哪里可能并不重要，但我确实想记住我的大学毕业典礼，或者我的
wedding day or the birth of my child. How do the salience of events change what we remember and what we forget? Well, yeah, so it's definitely true that most. of us will remember highly salient or highly emotional events with, you know, a lot more frequency. And a lot of that is that we tend to think about those events a lot more. We're more inclined to bring them to mind. So we do tend to think about things that have a lot of emotional resonance for us, either positive or negative. And one of the interesting things about that is that people tend to have very high confidence in those memories that they're particularly salient, so they think are particularly important. Like you mentioned, the birth of your child, or, you
婚礼那天，或者我孩子的出生。事件的显著性如何改变我们记住和忘记的内容？嗯，是的，所以这绝对是真的，我们大多数人会以更高的频率记住高度显著或高度情绪化的事件。其中很大一部分原因是我们往往会更多地思考这些事件。我们更有倾向把它们带回脑海。所以我们确实倾向于思考那些对我们有很高情感共鸣的事情，无论是积极的还是消极的。关于这一点，有趣的事情之一是，人们对那些特别显著的记忆往往有很高的自信，所以他们认为这些记忆特别重要。就像你提到的，你孩子的出生，或者，
know, like an accident that you were in or, you know, something kind of really that's maybe personal or of national or international importance, but that has some huge salience for you. You'll tend to remember that with really high confidence, but that confidence often doesn't come paired with actually very high accuracy. So when it comes to those highly emotional memories, our confidence in them can actually be misleading. So that salience, that emotional resonance can really lead us to thinking about those memories a lot, which means we're engaging in that act of reconstruction process a lot more frequently. And that actually means we're, in a way,
你知道的，比如你经历的一场事故，或者，你知道的，一些非常个人化的事情，或者具有国家或国际重要性，但对你有着巨大显著性的事情。你往往会以非常高的自信记住它，但这种自信往往并不伴随着非常高的准确性。因此，当谈到那些高度情绪化的记忆时，我们对它们的自信实际上可能是误导性的。所以这种显著性，这种情感共鸣确实会导致我们经常思考这些记忆，这意味着我们更频繁地参与这种重建过程。这实际上意味着，在某种程度上，
creating more opportunities for errors to creep into those memories. Okay, let's turn to listener questions now. Here's one from a listener named Shelley. I was diagnosed with ADHD at age 60 and I've had it all my life and that diagnosis explains a lot. And one of the things that I find the most distressing
我们正在为错误潜入这些记忆中创造更多的机会。好的，现在让我们转向听众的问题。这里有一个名叫雪莉的听众的问题。我在60岁时被诊断出患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD），我一辈子都有这个病，这个诊断解释了很多事情。我发现其中最令人痛苦的事情之一
about it is that my working memory is very poor. unless I very consciously plug into my body and say things like you put your car keys in your coat pocket instead of putting them back in your purse or, you know, your sunglasses are on the table, not in your purse. Don't forget where you put them. If I don't do that, then I feel like I'm wandering the world unconscious. I will be walking across the house with a tool in my hand to go do something and I get distracted and I set that tool down and I have the zero memory of having done it or where I put it and it I feel gaslit by myself like I am gaslighting myself and it makes me really crazy and undermines my confidence and I wonder if there are any
关于这一点，我的工作记忆非常糟糕。除非我有意识地与我的身体连接并说出这样的话：你把车钥匙放在外套口袋里了，而不是放回钱包里，或者，你知道的，你的太阳镜在桌子上，而不是在钱包里。别忘了你把它们放在哪里。如果我不那样做，那么我觉得自己就像在无意识地在世界上游荡。我会手里拿着一个工具穿过房子去做某事，然后我分心了，我把那个工具放下了，我对这样做过或者把它放在哪里完全没有记忆，我觉得自己被自己煤气灯化了（受到心理操控），就像我在对自己进行心理操控一样，这让我真的很疯狂并削弱了我的自信，我想知道是否有任何
exercises to do or any way to help make that better or at least not feel so bad about it. Thanks so much. So, Kira, we talked about having compassion for ourselves when we forget. But how do we do that if we are constantly forgetting things? Yeah. So I think it is important to recognize that we all forget these kinds of things all the time. So I think Shelley spoke very eloquently there about her issues with ADHD and that those attentional issues that can also, of course, very much play in with memory issues.
锻炼可以做，或者有什么方法可以改善这一点，或者至少不让感觉那么糟糕。非常感谢。那么，基拉，我们谈到了在忘记时对自己保持同情。但是如果我们不断忘记事情，我们该怎么做到这一点呢？是的。所以我觉得承认我们所有人一直都在忘记这些事情是很重要的。所以我想雪莉刚才非常生动地讲述了她与ADHD的问题，以及那些注意力问题，当然这也可能在很大程度上与记忆问题交织在一起。
But most of us, I think it's what's important to understand is that when somebody is diagnosed with a condition like ADHD or even maybe somebody who is aging and concerned about their memory with age, is that they become much more kind of laser focused on these kind of failures of memory and see everything as, oh God, that's a symptom. Whereas if, you know, you take somebody who doesn't have this condition or isn't concerned about it, they just won't tend to worry about these kinds of day-to-day failures. I was having a conversation the other day with a lady who was an older lady and she was talking about how, you know, she really got lost trying to find the room that we were meeting
但我们大多数人，我认为重要的是要了解，当一个人被诊断出患有像ADHD这样的疾病，或者甚至可能是某个正在变老并担心自己随年龄增长的记忆力的人时，他们会变得更加专注于这些记忆失败，并将每件事都视为“天哪，这是一个症状”。然而，如果你带一个没有这种病症或不担心它的人，他们通常不会担心这种日常的失败。我前几天和一个老妇人交谈，她谈到她是如何在试图找到我们开会的房间时迷路的
in in this building where I work. It was this really enormous sprawling building. And I was saying, you know, like I get lost in this building all the time and I've been working here for 10 years. If you were 25 and you got lost in that building, you would blame the building. You wouldn't blame your memory. But then in terms of kind of practical things that you can do, So firstly, it's really boring, but a lot of the time it's just having procedures. So it's just having things like habit is actually one of the most effective ways of helping with those kinds of day-to-day and kind of lapses of attention. So things like having a place, a really visibly obvious place where you always put your keys.
在我工作的这栋大楼里。这是一栋非常庞大、杂乱无章的大楼。我说，你知道的，就像我经常在这栋大楼里迷路一样，我已经在这里工作了10年了。如果你25岁，在这栋大楼里迷路了，你会责怪这栋大楼。你不会责怪你的记忆。但就你可以做的实际事情而言，首先，这真的很无聊，但在很多情况下，这只是拥有程序。所以这只是拥有诸如习惯之类的事情，实际上是帮助应对这些日常注意力和注意力不集中的最有效方法之一。所以诸如拥有一个地方，一个非常明显、你总是把钥匙放在那里的显眼地方。
Like, I don't have ADHD, but I still have a key hook behind my door. And if I don't put my keys on that key hook, I'm going to struggle to find them later. So I always try to remember to put the keys on that key hook. So just having those things and making them a habit, it won't work instantly, but making them a habit really does help because we will engage in that kind of habitual behavior without consciously thinking about it. And there are a lot of good kind of technological tools that you can use, even if it's just really simple things like using a calendar, using a to-do app, you know, using something that will give you reminders of, hey, you need to do this thing, don't forget about that. If you know I'm someone who's likely to get distracted and completely breeze past the meeting that's going on soon, set a reminder for yourself like 10 minutes before and then five minutes before and then at the meeting. So you're giving yourself warnings. And then you're just working with the way that your mind works, recognizing its strengths, but also recognizing its limitations and that you can work with those rather than trying to fight against them. We received a question from a listener named Tom. He's 49. years old and starting to worry about the things he forgets. I want to play you his question
就像我没有ADHD，但我仍然在门后有一个钥匙钩。如果我不把钥匙挂在那个钥匙钩上，我以后就会很难找到它们。所以我总是尽量记住把钥匙挂在那个钥匙钩上。所以只要有这些东西并使之成为习惯，它不会立即起作用，但将其付诸习惯确实有帮助，因为我们会在没有有意识思考的情况下参与这种习惯性行为。有很多很好的技术工具你可以使用，即使只是非常简单的事情，比如使用日历、使用待办事项应用程序，你知道的，使用会给你提醒的东西，嘿，你需要做这件事，不要忘记。如果你知道我是那种容易分心并且完全忽略即将到来的会议的人，请为自己设置一个提醒，比如提前10分钟，然后提前5分钟，然后在会议开始时。所以你在给自己警告。然后你只是顺应你的头脑运作的方式，认识到它的优势，但也认识到它的局限性，你可以利用这些而不是试图与它们对抗。我们收到了一个名叫汤姆的听众的问题。他49岁
and then ask for a clarification. I've noticed specifically, almost at 50, I lose nouns, I forget specific words. They're not gone entirely. They may come back. This seems like forgetfulness. But is it just being forgetful? Is it old age? Or is there something happening in the memory where the data bank is so full up, it might take a bit longer. to find that connection or is it a condition? I don't know. That's my question. Love your show. Thank you. So in some ways, Kira, I think Tom is saying that he is his own control group. He isn't comparing himself to somebody else. He's saying, compared to who I used to be, I feel like my memory is not what it was. I'm wondering how you would respond to someone like Tom, but also address his deeper
岁，开始担心他忘记的事情。我想放听众的问题给你听，然后请你澄清一下。我特别注意到，几乎到了50岁，我失去了名词，我忘记了特定的词。它们并没有完全消失。它们可能会回来。这看起来像是健忘。但这只是健忘吗？是老年吗？还是记忆中发生了什么，数据库太满了，可能需要更长的时间来找到那个连接，或者是一种疾病？我不知道。这就是我的问题。喜欢你的节目。谢谢。所以从某种程度上说，基拉，我认为汤姆是在说他是他自己的对照组。他不是在拿自己和别人比较。他说，比起过去的自己，我觉得我的记忆力不如从前了。我想知道你会如何回应像汤姆这样的人，同时解答他更深层次的问题
question, which is, how do you tell the difference between something that is just regular, normal forgetfulness and something that might be inching towards some kind of neurological condition. Yeah, and that's a really tricky question, and it is one that, of course, a lot of people have concern about. So first thing is to say that, yes, undeniably, a lot of aspects of our memory do decline with age. So the peak of our cognitive abilities is typically in our early 20s. So it's kind of downhill from there in terms of a lot of features. I find it myself that you have that sort of tip of the tongue effect where you're trying to to think of a word and it won't come to mind. And then later you want to be like, hey, everybody,
问题是，你如何区分仅仅是常规的、正常的健忘和可能正在向某种神经系统疾病靠拢的情况？是的，这是一个非常棘手的问题，当然这也是很多人关心的问题。所以首先要说的是，是的，不可否认的是，我们记忆的许多方面确实随着年龄的增长而衰退。我们认知能力的顶峰通常在我们20岁出头。所以在很多功能方面，可以说是走下坡路。我自己也发现你有那种舌尖效应，你试图想出一个词，但它就是想不起来。然后过一会儿你想说，嘿，大家，
I thought of it. I remembered the word. But, you know, I have a vocabulary. I haven't forgotten the words. I just couldn't think of it at that moment. So that is a very common experience. So, and again, I think it is a really interesting thing because this is where we have that sort of gray area. That with all of these things, so a lot of all of these kinds of day to day failures of memory, forgetting someone's name, forgetting a word, that sort of tip of the tongue feeling. These are really, really common things that everyone will experience from time to time, but they can also be an indicator of early stages of cognitive decline. And essentially it really comes down to the frequency of these issues. How frequently are they occurring? So what I would say
我想到了。我记起这个词了。但是，你知道的，我词汇量很丰富。我没有忘记这些词。我只是那一刻想不起来了。所以这是一种非常常见的体验。所以，再次重申，我认为这是一个非常有趣的事情，因为这就是我们拥有这种灰色地带的地方。对于所有这些事情，所有这些日常记忆失败、忘记某人的名字、忘记一个词、那种舌尖上的感觉。这些都是非常非常常见的事情，每个人都会时不时地经历，但它们也可能是认知能力下降早期的指标。从根本上说，这确实归结为这些问题的频率。它们发生的频率是多少？所以我想说的是
to someone is if this is something that happens occasionally, you're not really seeing, you know, other aspects of your life aren't showing significant signs of cognitive decline. It's probably not a big deal. If you think that there are other signs, so if you find, for example, that you often get confused or that you find that you're having more trouble regulating your emotions, those can be signs of kind of mild cognitive impairment or early stages of decline. And if someone does have any concern about their memory and about age-related memory decline, the first port of call really is to speak to your GP, your family doctor. Another important resource can be family members, in particular spouses,
对某人来说，如果这是一件偶尔发生的事情，你真的没有看到，你知道的，你生活的其他方面没有显示出认知能力明显下降的迹象。这可能不是什么大问题。如果你认为还有其他迹象，例如，如果你发现自己经常感到困惑，或者发现自己调节情绪变得更加困难，这些可能是轻度认知障碍或衰退早期阶段的迹象。如果有人对自己的记忆力和与年龄相关的记忆衰退有任何担忧，首要途径实际上是咨询你的全科医生，你的家庭医生。另一个重要的资源可以是家庭成员，特别是配偶，
because they often have a really have much more insight into our behavior than we might have for ourselves. So it can be helpful to say to a spouse, have you noticed any decline in my behavior? Have you noticed that I'm forgetting things more frequently? And if they say, no, it's the same as you always have been, then that's fine.
因为他们往往对我们的行为有比我们自己更深刻的洞察。所以对配偶说这样的话会很有帮助：你注意到我的行为有什么下降吗？你注意到我更频繁地忘事了吗？如果他们说，没有，你一直都这样，那就没问题了。
If they say, well, actually, maybe there's something, that can be something you do want to check out. One anxiety we hear about a lot these days is whether there's a link between new technologies and our ability to remember important information. In other words, do our phones rot our brains? Here's listener, Krista. I was just listening to Setting the Pass to Rest,
如果他们说，嗯，实际上，也许有什么不对劲，那可能是你想去检查一下的事情。我们现在经常听到的一个担忧是，新技术与我们记住重要信息的能力之间是否存在联系。换句话说，我们的手机会腐蚀我们的大脑吗？这里有听众，克里斯塔。我刚才在听《让过去安息吧》，
which was a fascinating episode. And I had a question about how much impact on our working memory does notification from cell phones and messaging apps have. This reminds me, Kira, of an episode we did with the psychologist Gloria Mark who found that people checked their email on average 77 times per day. Is it hard to focus and remember things
这是一个迷人的节目。我有一个问题，手机通知和消息应用对我们的工作记忆有多大影响？这让我想起，基拉，我们和心理学家格洛丽亚·马克做过的一期节目，她发现人们平均每天查看电子邮件77次。当我们的手机不断发出哔哔声并分散我们的注意力时，是不是很难集中注意力和记住事情
when our phones are constantly pinging and distracting us, Kira? I have to say, to me, 77 times a day seems like an underestimate. I can well believe it. So I think again, there's kind of this distinction here between attention and memory.
基拉？我不得不说，对我来说，一天77次似乎被低估了。我完全相信这一点。所以我认为，这里再次存在注意力与记忆之间的某种区别。
And they are very tightly interlinked. linked, but they are also different things. So a lot of the time what's happening there is our attention is constantly being interrupted by, you know, constant notifications, something buzzes. And those things really do kind of capture our attention. And that's, again, a kind of evolved mechanism that we have this attentional capture. But there isn't really any evidence that that's actually affecting the function of our memory. What it can do, of course, is because, say, something like working memory is essentially really a process of attention. Okay. So in order to, engage in working memory. So let's say I give you a list of words to remember and then I ask you to
它们紧密相连，但也是不同的东西。所以在很多情况下发生的事情是，我们的注意力不断被你知道的不断到来的通知、某种蜂鸣声所打断。这些事情确实抓住了我们的注意力。这也是一种进化的机制，我们拥有这种注意力捕捉机制。但实际上没有任何证据表明这真的在影响我们记忆的功能。当然，它能做的是，因为，比如说像工作记忆本质上真的是一个注意力过程。好吧。因此，为了参与工作记忆。比方说，我给你一个要记住的单词列表，然后我让你
repeat them back to me. Okay. That's a very conscious process. It requires a lot of attention to engage in that. If you get distracted, that information is gone. Okay. So during that kind of short term period, if your attention is distracted, then you're not encoding that information. Okay. It's not that it's been encoded and then it's been wiped out of your brain. It's that it didn't encode it properly in the first place. And that, in fact, a lot of the time when people talk about various failures of their memory, even in kind of things like, say, eyewitness memory, actually a lot of the time it's not a failure of memory at all.
把它们复述给我。好的。这是一个非常清醒的过程。参与其中需要大量的注意力。如果你分心了，这些信息就消失了。好的。所以在那个短期的时期内，如果你的注意力分散了，那么你其实就没有在编码这些信息。好吧。并不是说它已经被编码然后又从你的大脑中抹去了。而是因为它一开始就没有被正确编码。事实上，很多时候，当人们谈论记忆的各种失误时，甚至在像目击者记忆这样的一些事情上，其实很多时候根本不是记忆的失误。
It's that their attention was distracted, so they weren't saying they didn't encode the event. They were looking at their phones, so they didn't see the crime happening across the street. So I don't think it's the case that that technology is kind of hacking our brains or changing anything, but it is a case that it can sort of steal our attention away from where we want to be. I'm wondering though, Kira, I remember as a kid, I remember the phone numbers of probably 100 or 200 of my friends. I could remember all of their phone numbers. And of course, now I just put the phone numbers into my phone and I just look up their names and I press the button and I don't remember anyone's phone number. surely technology must be playing a role in what we choose to remember and how we remember?
而是他们的注意力被分散了，所以他们并不是说他们没有对这个事件进行编码。他们当时在看手机，所以没有看到马路对面发生的犯罪。所以我不认为这种技术是在黑我们的脑子或者改变什么，但它确实会把我们的注意力从我们想要关注的地方偷走。不过我在想，基拉，我记得我小时候，大概记得100到200个朋友的电话号码。我能记住他们所有的电话号码。当然，现在我只是把电话号码存进手机里，然后查名字，按按钮，我就不记得任何人的电话号码了。技术肯定在我们在选择记住什么和如何记住的事情上发挥了作用吧？
So I think those are two different things. Technology does play a role in what we choose to remember, but I don't think it affects how we remember. So the fundamental mechanism of memory is the same and has always been the same. What's different is what we choose to devote our attention to and what we choose to remember. I could still recite my best friend's phone number to you even like her home phone number from when she was a kid I could still recite that number to you now and that's because I dialed that number over and over and over again
所以我认为这是两码事。技术确实在 我们选择记住什么方面发挥了作用，但我不认为它会影响我们如何去记住。因此，记忆的基本机制是相同的，而且一直都是相同的。不同的是我们选择把注意力花在什么上面，以及我们选择记住什么。我仍然可以向你背诵我最好的朋友的电话号码，甚至像她小时候的座机号码，我现在仍然可以把那个号码背诵给你听，那是因为我一遍又一遍地拨打那个号码，
and I needed to know it because I was using a landline I don't need to know her cell phone number now I can just pick up my phone and call her so that's a matter of us deciding what's a good use of our mental resources we have a limited amount of attention to go around memory isn't really a limited resource but attention is
而且我需要知道它，因为我当时使用的是固定电话。我现在不需要知道她的手机号码，我可以直接拿起手机给她打电话。所以这是我们决定如何善用我们心理资源的问题。我们可用的注意力是有限的，记忆其实并不是一种有限的资源，但注意力是。
we have limited bandwidth we only have so much of it to go around and we choose to devote that to where we want to devote it and we don't always make those choices very well which is why we might spend time scrolling on Instagram
我们的带宽是有限的，我们只有那么多的注意力可以分配，我们选择把它投入到我们想要投入的地方，而我们并不总是能很好地做出这些选择，这就是为什么我们可能会花时间在Instagram上刷屏，
when we really should be working on a paper and yes I'm speaking about myself here you know but I'm still making that choice that I'm choosing to value what I'm the Instagram things and it may not be what I ought to value but it's what I'm choosing to direct my attention
而我们其实应该在写论文。是的，我这里也是在说我自己，你知道的，但我仍然在做出那种选择，我选择重视Instagram上的那些东西，这可能不是我应该重视的，但这就是我选择引导我注意力的地方，
to write now. I could choose to direct it elsewhere. But the fact that I'm choosing to do that doesn't mean that I've now lost the ability to write a paper. It's just that I'm directing my attention elsewhere. Our guest is psychologist Kira Green, who's joining us to answer listener questions about her work on memory and forgetting. More of those questions in a moment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is your questions answered, our segment in which we answer listeners follow-up questions
就在现在。我可以选择把它引导到别的地方。但我选择这样做，并不意味着我现在失去了写论文的能力。只是我把注意力引导到了别的地方。我们的嘉宾是心理学家基拉·格林，她来这里回答听众关于她对记忆和遗忘的研究的提问。稍后将回答更多此类问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是你的问题解答，在这个环节中，我们将回答听众关于我们在节目中探讨过的主题的后续问题
about ideas we've featured on the show. Today, we're talking with Kira Green. She researches the science of memory and forgetfulness at University College Dublin. Kira, a listener named Chris has an interesting question about how memory and forgetting work. Here he is. My question is, does the brain store memories thematically? You know, the reason I ask is I have really a terrible memory for my own personal history. But if something comes up in my life, immediately come to mind three or four other instances of my past
今天，我们和基拉·格林一起聊聊。她在都柏林大学学院研究记忆和健忘的科学。基拉，一位名叫克里斯的听众提出了一个关于记忆和遗忘如何运作的有趣问题。听听他是怎么说的。我的问题是，大脑是以主题的方式存储记忆的吗？你知道，我这么问是因为我对自己的个人历史记忆力真的很差。但如果我的生活中出现了什么事情，脑海中马上就会浮现出我过去的另外三四个例子，
where the same theme is evident. So I'm just amazed at the way the organization of the brain works. Thank you. So we've previously discussed how sad events in our lives can cause us to dredge up sad memories and happy events can make us remember happy memories. Is Chris on to something with his thesis about thematic memory, Kira? So, you know, it's a great question. And Chris is absolutely right.
在这些例子中，相同的主题显而易见。所以我对大脑组织运作的方式感到惊讶。谢谢你。所以我们之前讨论过，我们生活中的悲伤事件会导致我们勾起悲伤的回忆，而快乐的事件能让我们记住快乐的回忆。基拉，克里斯关于主题记忆的论点说得对吗？所以，你知道，这是一个很好的问题。克里斯完全说对了。
It's a really good way to think about memory in this way. So, yeah, memory is fundamentally associative. You have a particular memory and that activates a network of neurons in the brain. And then each of those neurons in that network are also linked. They're physically linked with other neurons, which are part of other networks in the brain. So you physically experience one memory and that literally sends an electrical signal that triggers a connected memory. So from a purely basic neurological perspective, that is exactly how it works. We also know that memories are stored in these kind of very associative patterns.
用这种方式来思考记忆真的很好。所以，是的，记忆从根本上说是联想性的。你有一个特定的记忆，这会激活大脑中的一个神经元网络。然后，这个网络中的每个神经元也都是相互连接的。它们与其他神经元物理连接，而这些神经元是大脑中其他网络的一部分。所以你亲身经历了某个记忆，这字面意思上会发送一个电信号，从而触发一个相关的记忆。因此，从纯粹的基础神经学角度来看，这正是它的工作原理。我们也知道，记忆就是以这种非常联想的模式存储的。
And I talked earlier on about this idea of how we sort of extract gist from our memories. And one of the things that we do with that is that we use them to build up these sort of blueprints, these schemas for our lives and for our expectations of the world. And a lot of that is essentially based on themes that we recognize the underlying commonalities between our experiences. Something happens to you. Think about some memory from your life. And that triggers another memory.
我前面谈到了这个观点，即我们如何从记忆中提取出大意。我们用它来做的事情之一就是，用它们来建立这些蓝图，也就是我们对生活以及对世界期望的图式。其中很大一部分本质上是基于我们认可的、我们经历之间的底层共性的主题。有些事情发生在你身上。想想你生活中的某个记忆。这就会触发另一个记忆。
And because that memory has a lot in common with this. one, there are going to be a lot of connections in common. So there's going to be a lot of those neural connections between those memories and you'll end up with this sort of domino effect then of all these kind of related memories being triggered. And those are going to be memories that are related in your mind. If I saw those three memories laid out as like video clips, I may or may not see them as being related. But they're related for you in some way. Maybe it's an emotional element. Maybe it has something to do with the setting. Maybe it has something to do with the people, whatever it is, there is some underlying commonality among those memories for you
由于那个记忆和这个记忆有很多共同之处，所以会有很多共同的连接。因此，这些记忆之间会有很多神经连接，最后你会得到一种类似多米诺骨牌效应的反应，所有这些相关的记忆都被触发了。那些将会是在你脑海中相关的记忆。如果我把这三段记忆像视频剪辑一样摆出来，我可能会也可能不会认为它们是相关的。但它们在某种程度上对你来说是相关的。也许是一个情感因素，也许与环境有关，也许与人有关，无论是什么，对你来说，这些记忆之间都有某种潜在的共性，
that your brain has extracted out that gist and recognized those as being similar. So yeah, absolutely, we do do that. In our previous conversation, you mentioned that on average, people tend to remember more positive events than negative ones. question from a listener named Joe about that idea. I have always heard about the negativity bias where you only can remember critical things or negative things that have happened to you or said about you and forget all the positive things. How does this relate to the concept of only holding on to positive memories of the past. This is a great question, Kira.
你的大脑已经提取出了那个大意，并认识到这些是相似的。所以，是的，绝对的，我们确实会这样做。在我们之前的对话中，你提到平均而言，人们倾向于记住比负面事件更多的正面事件。一位名叫乔的听众针对这个观点提出了一个问题。我一直听说过消极偏差，即你只能记住发生在你身上或关于你的关键事情或消极事情，而忘记所有积极的事情。这与只保留对过去的积极记忆的概念有何关系？这是一个很好的问题，基拉。
How does the negativity bias, which we have discussed at length on hidden brain, intersect with your research on memory? So in general, in autobiographical memory, we actually see a positivity bias, so that people will tend on average to remember events in a more positive light. Now, I think what's interesting about often happens is a very common thing that people will fall into, like, what Joe said there and what a lot of people will say is they'll say, so I'll only remember the negatives or I'll only remember the positives. But it's not really that. It is more of like a bias. It's more about like kind of slightly tilting the scales
我们在《隐藏的大脑》中已经详细讨论过的消极偏差，与你对记忆的研究是如何交织在一起的呢？因此，总的来说，在自传体记忆中，我们实际上看到了积极偏差，也就是说人们平均倾向于以更积极的视角来记住事件。现在，我认为有趣的是，通常发生的事情是人们常会陷入的一种非常常见的情况，就像乔刚才说的以及许多人会说的那样，他们会说，所以我就只记得消极的事情，或者只记得积极的事情。但其实并不是那样。这更像是一种偏差。它更像是稍微倾斜了天平，
in one direction or another. On the whole, for most people, on average, we tend to have this sort of positivity bias that leads us to remember our lives positively and to see the world through rose tinted glasses. But those are averages, okay? there are things that can affect that. And one of them is depression. So people are depressed. They're much more likely to experience that sort of more of a negativity bias. So if somebody is depressed and they have built up their kind of blueprint, their framework, their schema of the world, that schema is likely to be quite negative in tone. And it's likely to contain a lot of negative experiences. And then that means that people are likely to see the world through that more negative lens. In all of these things,
倒向某个方向。总的来说，对于大多数人，平均而言，我们往往会有这种积极偏差，引导我们积极地看待自己的生活，并通过玫瑰色的眼镜看待世界。但这些都是平均情况，好吧？有些事情会影响这一点。其中之一就是抑郁症。所以人们如果抑郁了，他们更有可能经历那种更多的消极偏差。因此，如果某人患有抑郁症，并且他们建立了自己的蓝图、框架、对世界的图式，那个图式在基调上很可能是相当消极的。并且它很可能会包含很多消极的经历。然后这就意味着人们更有可能通过那种更消极的镜片来看待世界。在所有这些事情中，
we talk about these, you know, very generic terms about grand averages, but there's also just a lot of individual differences in here in terms of individual people. And I think it's also, whenever I talk about this, and I mention this kind of positivity bias, somebody in the audience will always say, but I have these really, really vivid memories of terrible things that happen to me. And I'm like, yes, of course you do. Because, you know, we're not suggesting that there's a big eraser in the brain that just comes in and wipes out all your negative experiences. It's not that black and white. It's not that simple. Of course, those negative events are still there. Those
我们讨论这些（你知道的）关于宏观平均值的非常通用的术语，但这里也存在大量的个体差异，就具体的个人而言。而且我认为，每当我谈到这个并提到这种积极偏差时，观众中的某个人总会说，但我确实对发生在我身上的可怕事情有着非常非常生动的记忆。而我会说：是的，你当然有。因为，（你知道的）我们并不是暗示大脑中有一个巨大的橡皮擦，可以随时擦除你所有的消极经历。事情并非非黑即白。没有那么简单。当然，那些消极事件仍然存在。那些
can be very traumatic. Those can cast a big shadow on people's lives. But we're just saying that on average, over the course of all of your lives, all of the events of your life, you're likely to recall a lot of your past experiences in this slightly more positive light.
可能会非常具有创伤性。这些会给人们的生活投下巨大的阴影。但我们只是说，平均而言，在你所有的生活历程中，你生活的所有的事件中，你很可能会以这种稍微更积极的眼光来回忆你过去的很多经历。
We received several questions from listeners who were interested in the relationship between grief and memory. Here's one from a listener in Uganda, named Amansi Mickey. I had a question directed to Kiarra Green about memory. Could she get into more detail on psychology about people who move on potentially first
我们收到了几位听众的问题，他们对悲伤和记忆之间的关系很感兴趣。这里有一个来自乌干达的名为阿曼齐·米奇的听众的问题。我有一个针对基拉·格林关于记忆的问题。她能否更详细地从心理学的角度谈谈那些可能率先从改变人生的事件（比如失去父母或失去祖父母）中走出来的人？
from a life-altering event, like losing a parent or losing a grandparent? I wanted to understand that more. And if she has any ways, someone can get back to a memory like that to bitter understand themselves. Thank you. So I think it can be a painful aspect of the grieving process, Kira, to feel like you're starting to forget
我想更多地了解这一点。如果她有什么方法可以让一个人重新回到那样的记忆中，以更好地了解自己。谢谢。所以我想这可能是悲伤过程中痛苦的一个方面，基拉，你会觉得自己开始忘记了
key details about someone you've lost. But at the same time, it could be that this forgetting is an important part of healing. And I think Amanzi is getting at this question about how we can move on from intense grief while still cherishing and remembering our ancestors. What do you think, Kira?
关于你所失去的人的关键细节。但与此同时，这种遗忘也可能是治愈的重要组成部分。我想阿曼齐触及到了这个问题，即我们如何在保持对先辈的珍视和记忆的同时，从强烈的悲伤中走出来。你觉得呢，基拉？
Yeah, I think this is something that a lot of people of course have a lot of concerns about and it's often one of the worst parts of grief is that sense that you're starting to forget the person and that they're drifting away and that of course there's no more new memories with that person coming so I'm not sure there really is a straightforward answer to how we can avoid that because we can never really avoid the natural course of memory. I mean of course what we can do is to try and keep someone's memory alive is talk to other people about them. And and then keep, so rather than having their memory sort of preserved in amber in your own brain, that you're keeping it active, you're keeping it engaged by talking to other people by getting
是的，我认为这当然是很多人非常关心的事，而且这往往是悲伤中最糟糕的部分之一，那种你开始忘记这个人、他们正在逐渐走远的感觉，当然，和这个人之间也不会再有新的记忆了，所以我不确定对于我们如何避免这种情况是否真的有一个直接的答案，因为我们永远无法真正避开记忆的自然规律。我的意思是，当然，我们可以做的是，为了让某人的记忆保持鲜活，可以和别人谈论他们。然后保持，所以与其把他们的记忆像琥珀一样保存在你自己的大脑里，不如让它保持活跃，通过与其他人交谈来让他们参与进来，
their experiences of what that person was like and incorporating those into your own memory. And in many ways, that kind of flexibility of memory then can allow you to incorporate other people's perspectives into your memory and your understanding of that person and can help keep their memory alive and keep their memory fresh. But yeah, I'm afraid I don't actually, I don't really have any tips for how to not forget somebody. I'm afraid that is just sometimes the way things go. And in some ways, Kira, you know, when we talk to other people about someone we love and try and remember things together, you're also getting at the idea that memory can be a social process.
了解他们对那个人的印象，并将这些融入到你自己的记忆中。在许多方面，记忆的这种灵活性可以让你把其他人的观点融入到你的记忆和对那个人的理解中，并可以帮助保持那个记忆的鲜活和新鲜。但是的，恐怕我确实没有，我真的没有任何关于如何不忘记某个人的秘诀。恐怕事情有时就是这样的。从某种意义上说，基拉，你知道，当我们和别人谈论我们爱的人并试着一起回忆事情时，你也触及了这样一个观点，即记忆可以是一个社会化的过程。
It's not just reconstructed, of course, just in our own heads, but it can be sometimes reconstructed collectively. Yes, so we talk about this idea of collaborative memory. so people remembering together and that's often framed in a very negative way so for example we'll have in the forensic literature
它不仅是在我们自己的脑海中被重构的，当然，它有时也可以被集体重构。是的，所以我们谈论协作记忆这个概念。也就是人们一起回忆，这通常被构建在一个非常消极的方式中，例如，我们在法医文献中
we'll have a discussion of co-witness effects which is the idea that let's say I witness car crash and then you witness that car crash too and then we talk about it later and you tell me about some detail I didn't see and that contaminates my memory of the event we might see that as oh now my memory
会有关于同伴目击者效应的讨论，这个概念是，比方说我目睹了一场车祸，然后你也目睹了那场车祸，接着我们后来谈论起这件事，你告诉我一些我没有看到的细节，这就污染了我对这件事的记忆。我们可能会认为，哦，现在我的记忆
has been contaminated my memory has been altered and this is terrible because my memory has changed. But actually what a lot of the evidence shows is that this kind of collaborative memory, on average, ends up meaning that the group on average ends up with a better memory with more details of the event. So you and I together will recall more details of the crash than either one of us would have done on our own. So that's in a very forensic context. But of course this applies in other kind of social contexts as well, that memory is collaborative, that we often work with other people, maybe without thinking that. But just in the
已经被污染了，我的记忆被篡改了，这太糟糕了，因为我的记忆变了。但实际上，大量证据表明，这种协作记忆平均下来意味着，最终这个群体平均会得到一个更好的记忆，带有更多事件的细节。所以你和我一起会回忆起更多关于车祸的细节，比我们任何一个人独自回忆的都要多。所以那是在一个非常法医的语境下。但当然这也适用于其他一些社会语境，即记忆是协作的，我们经常与其他人一起工作，也许并没有意识到这一点。但在我们日常对话的
course of our day-to-day conversations, when we're remembering events for talking about them, the way even that we discuss the same event with different people can be completely different and that can trigger us to remember an event in a different way, to give it a different sort of emotional tone to remember or recall different details. And then maybe that memory gets slightly altered when we kind of reconsolidated when we lock it back down again. But that really kind of social process of memory, I think is something that is often overlooked. But memory, I just say, it isn't happening in our, you know, it isn't happening locked away in a little box. You know, our brains might be inside our skulls, but our minds are out there and engaged in a social setting.
过程中，当我们回忆事件并讨论它们时，甚至我们与不同的人讨论同一事件的方式也可能完全不同，这会触发我们以不同的方式回忆事件，赋予它不同的情感基调，去回忆或记起不同的细节。然后也许当我们重新巩固它、把它重新锁定时，那个记忆会稍微被修改。但我认为，记忆的那种真正的社会化过程往往被忽视了。但我只想说，记忆并非发生在我们的，你知道，它不是被锁在一个小盒子里的。你知道，我们的大脑可能在头骨里面，但我们的思想是在外面并参与到一个社交环境中的。
And our minds are constantly in contact with other people's minds. And we're getting information from other people and social cues from other people. And all of that helps to construct a memory that sometimes seems to be outside of one person. It's a memory that's shared by a group. And that's, I think that's actually a really valuable thing. Kira Green is a psychologist at University College Dublin. She's author of Memory Lane, the perfectly imperfect ways we remember. Kira, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain.
而且我们的思想不断地与别人的思想接触。我们从其他人那里获取信息和社交线索。所有这些都有助于构建一个有时似乎超越个人的记忆。这是一个由群体共享的记忆。我认为这实际上是一件非常宝贵的事情。基拉·格林是都柏林大学学院的心理学家。她是《记忆小巷：我们记忆中完美的不完美方式》一书的作者。基拉，非常感谢你今天再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus.
谢谢邀请我。本节目由《隐藏的大脑》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢我们在节目中探讨的理念，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅，《隐藏的大脑+》。
It's where you'll find conversations you won't hear anywhere else. We're offering an extended 30-day free trial of Hidden Brain Plus in the month of September for all listeners who sign up on Apple Podcasts. To try Hidden Brain Plus for free for 30-day, days, find Hidden Brain in the Apple Podcasts app and click the try-free button or go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话。我们在九月份为所有在苹果播客上注册的听众提供延长的30天免费试用。要免费试用30天，请在苹果播客应用中找到《隐藏的大脑》，然后点击免费试用按钮，或者访问apple.com/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。